Speaker 1: So I've been taking some shots
from the audience about I guess some people
in the audience think I'm too empathetic,
I'm I'm too empathetic when it comes to people
that haven't gotten vaccinated and then get
very sick or sometimes die.
Yeah, I feel bad for those people.
If if you want to attack me for being too
empathetic, I will take it.
It doesn't seem like the worst character flaw
to have.
But I have an example for you today of someone
who is apparently in a really bad position
and I don't really feel bad.
And maybe now people will be mad that I don't
feel bad.
But the latest report is that Rudy Giuliani
is reportedly close to broke and now Donald
Trump seems to have cut him off as well.
There's a very interesting article in Mother
Jones which says, Having raised more money
than anyone else in the Republican Party so
far this year, new filings show Donald Trump
is flush with cash.
Now, later, we'll talk about what he's doing
with some of that cash.
And it's very grifter's, absolutely swimming
in it.
But even as the money flows in, the former
president is reportedly stiffing one of his
fiercest allies and loyal political surrogates,
Rudy Giuliani, as the former New York mayor
becomes increasingly ensnared in a federal
investigation, reportedly costing him millions
in legal fees.
Here is the latest on the apparent fallout
between the two men.
Maggie Haberman tweeted, Giuliani allies are
looking at the Trump money even if it is an
82 million and are aghast that Trump isn't
helping Giuliani with legal fees.
Trump doesn't care about anybody when they
are no longer useful to him.
That's what that's always the case.
It's no different with Rudy.
Maggie goes on to tweet.
Giuliani's friends say he is close to broke
and his interview with Melissa Russo makes
clear he knows he's in legal jeopardy.
Going on to say Trump aides have been clear
they see no mechanism for paying Rudy's legal
bills.
That isn't problematic for Trump.
And they think Giuliani took actions as a
lawyer should have known were problematic.
Strange phrasing, but I understand what it
says, even if the client wanted it, that's
particularly worrisome for Giuliani, whose
legal defense fund has effectively failed
to raise anything in his fight against the
federal probe into whether he worked as an
unregistered lobbyist for Ukrainian officials.
Giuliani, who was recently suspended from
practicing law in New York, is also facing
a separate lawsuit from Dominion voting systems
over his relentless election lies.
And despite his penchant for conspiracy theories
and misinformation, it appears, as Haberman
notes, that Giuliani does seem to understand
the gravity of his precarious legal situation.
So this is a disaster for Rudy, but it is
really a deserved one, quite frankly.
I mean, you know that this guy is an adult.
He was a competent lawyer.
He didn't so much fall for something as he
made some kind of calculation that he was
going to get involved and defend everything
Trump does no matter what, and even go above
and beyond, not just while Trump was trying
to be reelected.
Trump loses and then Rudy becomes the front
person, the most prominent person going around
the country, spreading covid and also spreading
bogus hypotheses about how Trump actually
won.
He turned himself into a pawn for a psychopathic,
narcissistic egomaniac.
That was Donald Trump.
How else was this ultimately going to end?
And a little bit later, we're going to talk
about new reports that Donald Trump has been
funneling the grifter's 80 million or 72 million
or whatever he raised over the last few months
to fight the election results.
He's been funneling it into his own businesses,
but he's not going to pay Rudy Giuliani's
legal fees.
So what options does Rudy have close to?
Broke a couple of things that come to mind.
One, I don't know if you remember, but there
was there were a few instances where Rudy
mentioned that he has an insurance policy.
He said that he has this insurance policy,
which is some kind of evidence of Trump wrongdoing,
and that if he were to have a problem with
Trump, he would have this evidence of some
kind as an insurance policy.
Did he really have that?
We don't know.
Did he have it?
But maybe it's not really a value anymore
because it's part of what was seized when
his home and office were raided by federal
authorities a month or two ago.
We don't know, is Rudy going to have to flip,
although then it actually raises questions.
You know, it's really it's complicated because
Rudy was Trump's lawyer, but he was really
only like his TV lawyer until after the election.
Rudy actually started filing motions and courts,
but then Trump sort of distance.
And it's not clear whether that was really
a representation.
The point is, if Rudy were to think about
flipping and I don't know that he's thinking
of that, but if he were, is there a question
of attorney client privilege somewhere in
there?
I don't know.
But it shouldn't shock any of us that Rudy
didn't end up getting 20 million a day from
Trump, who notoriously stiffs everybody that
works for him.
So Rudy is in a bad place.
I you know, it's it's hard for me not to feel
a little bad.
The guy is nearly 80.
He may be broke.
I feel a little bad.
I do.
But this is really of his own doing.
It's not even like Rudy, you know, an anti
VAX person who's the victim of disinformation,
propaganda all around them.
They go to work and it's Antibalas propaganda.
They go on Facebook, it's Antibalas propaganda.
Then they get sick with covid.
I see them really as as mostly victims, although
they are also perpetrators by continuing to
signal boost the Antibalas propaganda.
Rudy is not really a victim here.
Rudy Rudy is just a lawyer.
And he made a bad call.
He made the wrong decision.
And now he's going to have to apparently pay
the price
for
it